wintereinbruch in bayern unwetterartige
neuschneemengen sind für den süden
deutschlands angesagt doris hollberg aus
schliersee in der nähe von münchen freut
sich das ist mein lieblingswetter von
mir aus kann's elf monate so bleiben
die natur ist schön sauber frisch nicht
zu kalt herrlich der deutsche
wetterdienst meldet in seinem
warnlagebericht ergiebigen schneefall im
süden mit bis zu 50 cm neuschnee
besonders an den alpen und im
alpenvorland könne es demnach zu teils
erheblichen problemen im auto und
schienenverkehr kommen für schliersee
bewohner joachim brunner kein grund zur
sorge
es ist winter und es ist das passende
wetter zog
und da muss man sich darauf einstellen
wenn das wetter nicht anders ist dann
wird geschimpft darüber dass das wetter
nicht zur jahreszeit was ich glaube es
ist so wie es ist wenn man muss
vorsichtig autofahrer muss sich anpassen
muss das richtige anziehen und dann wenn
man es genießen kann
was genau soll das genießen auch in der
kommenden woche erwartet der deutsche
wetterdienst weiterhin schneefälle im
süden und gebietsweise sturmböen im
westen und nordwesten des landes